quelle est la différence entre une
gastro une voiture électrique et aucune
différence était très content c'est
arrivé à la maison
c'est une fille à rentrer dans un sex
shop ai dit tu auras le sextoy rose la
joie aussi le gros en noir est le plus
gros en rouge et les mecs 10 pour les
deux premiers pas de problème pour les
secteurs je demande au patron
c'est une femme elle pleure elle est à
la maternité elle pleure elle regarde
son bébé elle est en larmes elle lui dit
quand je pense qu'il ya neuf mois j'ai
faillite avaler
un petit garçon ayant dans la salle de
bain et sa mère sort de la douche nu il
regarde le sac de sa mère et lui dit
maman c'est quoi ça il va mettre un
petit peu je n'ai dit les jib à ça c'est
le bon dieu tu sais le bon dieu a créé
l'homme il a créé la femme
et puis quand il a créé la famille l'a
vu qu'il manque un détail donc il a été
dans sa caisse à outils il a pris une
petite hache et il a fait une incision
et le wat pho non non non merde en plein
dans la chatte
du jeune et rentre dans un bar et dit
j'aurais dit oui ce qui est le barman un
peu interloqué il fait dit oui ce qui
dit oui mais témoigne du whisky et le
barman fait pardon mais c'est pas
courant si vous commandez dit whisky
c'est que vous devez traiter quelque
chose et la jeune fille oui aujourd'hui
c'était ma première pipe obama mais
écoutez c'est toute ma jeunesse qui
monte à la gueule sa propre affaire
mettez moi de vous offrir le 11e fait
non j'espère que dit ça suffira à faire
passer le goût
différent de chez lui et sa femme est
appelée sur le canapé le mec à rentrer
chez lui un canard dans les bras et
terrestres et canards et des tables j'ai
une grosse truie un pas familier
n'importe quoi c'est pas une truite
c'est un canard fait ta gueule je te
parle patois
c'est sahara se réveille avenue foch
dans l'appartement est la tête dans le
cul après un café rendent dans le salon
et voilà et voit le et voile gauguin
gauguin est rayé ya marqué ça
elle va dans la cuisine il ya van gogh
paul gauguin y ait marqué sahara est là
dans son bureau il ya un renoir renoir
est rayé il ya marqué saraiva d'en
livrer david qu'est ce que tu appelles
chez toi et tes toiles de maîtres qu'est
ce que tu as fait ta gueule j'ai un
contrôle chez tous mes atouts non
un avion qui se crashe 400 morts il ya
trois survivants
le pilote le copilote et une hôtesse à
leur image jusqu'à jusqu'à l'arrivée
il il ya de l'eau il ya des poissons il
ya de quoi péché ils ont quoi faire du
feu et ils arrivent à survivre ils font
des signaux il n'ya pas d'avion qui
passe ya pas de bateau qui passait au
bout de trois mois depuis la glisse est
bien beau mais quand même sexuellement
fera peut-être qu'on s'organise vous
proposez quoi l hôtesse dit mais moi ça
me dérange pas on peut faire un jour toi
et un jour toi il marche comme ça
pendant un an et au bout d'un an en
ramassant des fruits l'hôtesse était
piquée par un serpent venimeux et le
moment elle meurt elle aimante voilà et
donc c'est très triste c'est tout et
puis au bout de trois mois pilote idéaux
copilote bon voilà lavier continue
sexuellement qu'est ce que tu proposes
guibert coûte on peut faire comme on
faisait avant on peut faire un coup toi
ou moi on alterne ok ok ils font ça tout
au bout de six mois il ôte idéaux
copilote et vous tu veux que je te parle
j'en peux plus ça me plaît pas ça me
dégoûte j'en peux plus et le copilote
dit charabi tu me dis ça parce que c'est
pas mon truc non plus j'en peux plus ça
me dégoûte qu'est ce que tu proposes
sediba le mieux ce serait con
l'enterrent
une femme guinéenne sont arides pardon
mais tu baises vraiment comme un lapin
qui fait mais comment tu peux me juger
en 30 secondes
un garçon ne peut pas pour aller à la
piscine papapapa deux mois 5 euro bonds
à la piscine le père et fait qu'outre
benjamin tu connais le tarif écoute
benjamin tu connais le tarif au non papa
me dis pas qu'il faut encore je te sus
le kaki
et de deux un couple d'homosexuels ils
sont dans l'avion sur un long courrier
je l'adoré ça c'est une de mes côtés il
y en a qui disent chalet prends-moi du
pardon dû prendre moi j'ai envie prends
moi mais limitée folle mais t'as vu on
est dans un avion il ya du monde mais
c'est un encore y ait tout le monde dort
on fera pas de bruit tout le monde dorme
était folle j'ai pas de prendre mais tu
es folle mais je te dis que tout le
monde dort tout le monde dorme prends
moi j'ai envie maintenant miss les gens
vont se réveiller tu veux je te montre
que personne sur la veille regarde bien
il se lève et crie est ce que quelqu'un
aurait un ch'ti nord
et dans l'avion peint bruit tout le
monde dort dit tu apprends moi lotfi
d'accord et au petit matin et l'hôtesse
de l'air le président leur a fait sa
tournée et voit une petite mamie qui
grelotte dans son siège et dit madame
vous avez froid dit je tremble de froid
j'ai eu très froid j'ai eu froid toute
la nuit dit mais madame pourquoi vous
n'avez pas réclamer une couverture fait
une couverture cette nuit il y en a un
qui a demandé un stylo il fonctionner
toute l'année c'est demain qui s'empare
ya vraiment deux potes il s'en va les
voir morts puis bouaflé coupe il ya des
[ __ ] ça va chier je vois encore rentré
bourg et ma femme va encore m'engueuler
comme tous les soirs ils sont pas 10
mais elle a raison que j'ai été con
comme une pile franchement une solution
pour qu'elles veulent pas moi je le fais
chez moi est ce que toi je sais comment
tu rends curan thébaux qui titube tu
farfouille dans la serrure qui fait des
bruits tu allumes tout tu renverses les
meubles tu arrives dans la chambre à
l'émeute ou tu te réveilles heigl méfie
pour une fois avant de rentrer et on
respire un grand coup tu choisis bien
taclé tu fais pas d'erreur tu fais pas
de bruit tu n'a lui même rien qu'une ne
bouscule pas les meubles tu te glisse
doucement tu te déshabille doucement tu
te glisse dans le lit et tu bouffes le
cul de ta femme
et si tu te bouffe bien le cul quand on
fait si tu l'as fait jouir
mais tu ne rend aucun reproche pour
avaler dans le frigo de problèmes bière
elle te [ __ ] à l'appel mais qui dit
ouais c'est génial ça s'arrose ils
reçoivent des coups bas il arrive chez
lui à 3 heures du mat fait pas respire
un grand coup il a 4 grammes tout à fait
qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré bien
choisir la clé bien choisis avec les
rangs doucement de rien à lui mais
devront repérer les mom de patti tube
est rentré dans la chambre doucement se
déshabiller se glisser dans le lit et là
ils bouffent le cul de sa femme qui dort
profondément
et elle bouge pas une oreille au bout
d'une demi heure rien et trois quarts
d'heure il commence à avoir mal aux
mâchoires et tous les leaders ils
entendent qui couine - ouais c'est bon
ça commence à chauffer une heure une
heure et demie et au bout de deux heures
il a une exclusion sont sous la couette
enfin le mec il est autant qu il osé et
là il prend la couette et il va dans la
cuisine boire sa bière qui l'a bien
mérité et là il va dans la clinique il
allume et voit sa femme qui boit un café
dans laquelle il dit mais qu'est ce que
tu fais là pas le point fort il ya maman
qui dort dans la chambre
[Rires]
basse et le belge il va voir le médecin
le médecin lui dis pardon mais j'ai une
très très mauvaise nouvelle pour vous il
vous reste deux mois à vivre le belge
iba alors je vais prendre juillet août
un vieux compositeur qui a écrit des
symphonies toute sa vie il avait tout
son coeur tout son art il n'a jamais
vendu une musique de sa ville à 78 ans
il habite la même chambre de bonne de
puits depuis des lustres et un jour il
reçoit un coup de téléphone d'une
production qui les écoutent monsieur
lavis la sacem votre catalogue et on
prend un film on a décidé de prendre une
de vos musiques donc quand ça est ce que
vous êtes d'accord la mecque oui ça fait
des années que j'attends scheid écoutez
donc on à votre accord quand le film
s'offre en vous vous enverra une
invitation pour la première et tout un
an après reçoit un carton d'invitation
pour la première du film alors il met
son vieux smoking tout mythe et il prend
un taxi va à l'adresse ils trouvent le
quartier un peu sordide mais bon il a un
peu étonné et voit le cinéma c'est un
petit cinéma de quartier et et il rentre
et il ya deux personnes dans la salle
juste un couple de petits vieux dans la
salle la salle est vide pour une
première très étonné alors pour pas pour
pas être trop trop seul il savait
derrière les petits vieux le film
démarre ça s'appelle [ __ ] à tort sa
porno bien sûr il admet qu'il défendrait
il est effondré c'est un mec s'appelle
l'accusateur ils seront embauchés dans
l'entente à châteaulin que la châtelaine
après que j'aie de la vie de l'achat de
la nuit à rennes baronne qui passe il
naquit la baronnie lenclud la bonne est
inculpé l'air sympa ce film au qu'il a
tort
et le mec est consterné quoi toute sa
vie pour ça il est il est consterné
abandonné et un chien qui passe quand il
attend un chien ils en ont ils encore le
chat et coatélan que le chien il ya une
musique qui démarche et c'est sa musique
non et là le mec il ya l'émotion qui le
gagne il est il est partagé entre la
honte et l'émotion et comme il n'a
jamais entendu sa musique dans une salle
de spectacle il coule une petite larme
mais une langue qui perlent long de sa
joue il a envie de profiter de ce moment
de partage et à quelqu'un qui fait que
les petits vieux demande et il épouse
hildy ceva musique et les vieux se
retourne en larmes c'est notre chien
c'est un gorille il se réveille tous les
matins et cette table sur le temps c'est
fait je suis le gorille onduleurs et
tous les jours ils enclins à nîmes je
crois que c'est une blague mais en fait
ça il existe heureusement cette blague
oui oui oui et donc une année molle
chaque jour et doit on a un jour il en
tue l'info milliers un jour il inclut
une gazelle un jour un jour il en cuma
phacochères un jour il [ __ ] à un
crocodile et puis un jour ils se
baladent [ __ ] chez le gorille
enculeurs [ __ ] le seul animal que
chalon acculé c'est c'est le lion le roi
des animaux je suis dégoûté et je
promets dit qu'est ce qu'ils voient un
point d'eau le lion dans toute sa
splendeur et sa crinière accroupi comme
ça le cul tendu retrouve voir
il arrive doucement à pas feutrés où mme
guidan qui est donc très très vite très
vite le nom il se retourne cette
expression héroïque et mon cul pour le
gorille et jouit et part en courant et
le lion c'est quoi c'est scandaleux
c'est par rapport à ma position je peux
pas admettre ça sinon après je vends que
veut dire la savane et ou équivalent et
cavale et puis et puis le gorille il
fait plein le c chaud il court plus vite
que moi tu haïkus et le lion et
développe sa foulée et le gorille y voit
que lyon égale du terrain il est un peu
dans le pays mais il voit une cabale il
rentre dans les cabanes il prend images
il m'a un chapeau des lunettes de soleil
il prend ainsi gary les croisés gens me
regardent le journal et le lien il
arrive comme un fou il fait vous
n'auriez pas vu un un gorille le gorille
ebay ce journal il dit vous voulez
parler de gorille qui a reculé le lion
le lion est énoncé déjà dans le journal
à mes docteurs je comprends pas j'ai des
poils partout sur les seins attention
sur le ventre et étoiles c'est pas
normal mais qui dit heureux que c'est
normal je vais enlever votre camp sage
et là il est sidéré elle a des poils sur
le coup les poils sur les seins à des
poètes sur levante il dit attendez
attendez ça court jusqu où comme ça fait
juste qu'aucun